so let's get you to your top five
takeaways derek carr as you go through
this coaching transition gruden out of
the building a new coach steps in
special teams coordinator it is what
have you seen from derek carr's game
after the transition
well you know we talked about it and we
said you know maybe he gets better and
it just seems like he's starting to get
better he doesn't have to worry about
anybody micromanaging them just think
about this jack think about every time
you come out of the huddle or you come
after a play the coach is telling you oh
you didn't drop too fast you should've
you should have read your second read as
opposed to your number one read
he no longer has to worry about groot
and criticizing him or critiquing him on
every single play and it just seems like
it's completely freedom up he's playing
relax this dude is playing some of the
best football that he's ever played so
it's like yep
hey man he's actually gotten better he's
actually gotten better since john
gruden's departure it's crazy i've never
seen anything like it
it's a point you really can't argue 31
of 34. he completed 91 percent of his
passes 91 that's the second highest
completion percentage the second highest
pass attempts to completions in the
history of the nfl the only guy to ever
have a better game was drew brees and
drew brees hit all those quick stuff
quick easy passes but he was hitting
everything nine different receivers he
hit
seven of them with multiple catches more
than three catches on the outside so
he's getting the ball to everybody
darren waller not even one of those to
give you some idea how deep down the
depth chart he was going to get these
passes out 49 of 61 for 664 yards and
four touchdowns that's what he's done in
the two games since gruden's left he
looks like he's playing free he looks
like he's having fun and the raiders the
raiders are still a super bowl contender
right now that's a crazy thought
especially with what's happening to
kansas city the raiders are still right
in the middle of this picture if derek
carr keeps playing like this and the one
thing the guy that you didn't mention is
josh jacobs when he was when he's
healthy
he is so big fast and strong and he
gives them so much energy and so much
power you can see it from the offensive
line that offensive line that extra
strep step is a little faster those guys
play with a different sense of urgency
when josh jacobs there but the main
thing is keeping him healthy and i don't
care if you have to rotate him maybe he
gets 15 at 17 carries a game as opposed
to 20 to 25 carries a game but yeah
having josh jacobs back plus max crosby
on the defensive side of the ball
you never know with the raiders i'm not
sitting here buying into the raiders
like really buying into them but hey the
raiders are right there pretty good team
i can't say that i'm not buying into
them either like i just i every week i'm
watching my car is carr is playing rich
versace i think he deserves credit i
mean that's a that's a really hard
circumstance to step into as an interim
head coach but but probably more than
him i got to give credit to derek carr
just as a leader just leadership i just
think for him to rally that entire
locker room and to go play like this i
got to give some serious credit to the
quarterback let's move to your second
takeaway and it's jamar
chase you were throwing out his name as
the best receiver in football on sunday
you've had a chance now to go watch the
game film watch the tape back do you
still feel pretty confidently in that or
where is he among the best in the entire
nfl
who's better
who's better right now who's better than
jamar chase right now at this point
because when i watch him he looks like a
bigger faster younger version of odell
beckham he can do everything he can beat
you deep he can take a slant he can
split between two or three defenders and
he's big and strong so if you hit him
you know the run after the catch is
ridiculous
and he's just he's just a
athletic freak and you know looking at
him in the preseason and he was dropping
everything i never thought that this kid
was this good i'm looking at how did the
cincinnati bengals draft him overall at
the fifth overall pick and now i see i
mean this dude is strong he's confident
and i mean look at the speed in an
explosion nobody's going to catch this
guy
he's a problem man he's a problem like
you use the odell beckham jr analogy and
i think it's very real he looks like
odell beckham jr before obj had about
eight injuries derail some of his
explosiveness and exciting plays on the
outside he just looks so fresh man he
has more receiving yards through seven
games than any rookie in nfl history any
you think about some of these receivers
randy moss you think about some of the
best justin jefferson had a great year
more than any ever marlon humphries he
isn't allowed a hundred yard receiver on
the outside since 2019 week two of 2019
the bengals they got him for 227
yards on humphreys humphreys alone 227
yards 165 of those belong to jamar chase
so he's doing it in man coverage he's
doing it against elite players and he is
dominating him i think he has a legit
case right now maybe he and cooper cup
for the best receiver in football
you know what if i had to pick right now
just based off of performances and
cooper cup is my man the jamar chase
that dude is so explosive i mean he's
that like i said he can take a slant
cooper cup he'll take a slant and he'll
get tackled maybe 15 20 yards down the
field he takes a slant he's going to
break two or three tackles and he's
going to split the difference and take
it to the house i love both of those
guys
and this uzama as well for for the
bengals i was just watching the game
back right before we came on the tight
end and i thought he was just a part of
the show a featured attraction he was
the show against the ravens how many
times did he have two or three yards
separation he's he's a big bodied man i
thought what stood out about him
listening to joe burrow is he said it's
the most impressive dialogue that he's
ever had with one of his tight ends the
most impressive dialogue and what he
what he described that was every time he
has a route catch or drop incomplete
whether he even got the ball or not he
comes back and he and burro have a
conversation about why he got the ball
or why he didn't get the ball and then
they learned from that and he said every
time uzama comes back it's the most
impressive conversation and that's why
he's now getting the targets size speed
and intelligence that's a scary
combination we think about
tyler boyd jamar chase t higgins uzama
joe mixon this a playoff team and this
may be more than a playoff team right
now in cincinnati
yeah you mentioned marlon humphrey and i
want to go back to him because he's
getting paid a lot of money he had a
huge contract and he's he's not playing
well right now he remember against the
raiders he got beat for the game winner
and he's not just getting beat by the
number one receiver zay jones is a third
receiver and if you go down the list of
big plays that he's given up this year
he has not played well and this is a guy
that they do a lot of different things
with they put him on tight ends they put
them in a slot they put them out wide
maybe they need to reduce all the
different things that he that he's doing
right now because he's all over the
place and he's not playing his best
football
that's it let's get to your second
takeaway let's see where you're looking
with number two you win this should be
your third the titans the tennessee
titans rod
tennessee they are beating some of the
best teams in the afc some of the best
teams in the nfl at what point do we
start talking about the titans as the
best i know right um and and what i'm
seeing is the titans are really starting
to turn into a complete team and we we
know about derrick henry his ability
whether it's you know what do you do you
got
when those wide receivers are healthy
you got two pro bowl and you got one
future hall of famer and julio jones
what are you going to do are you going
to play eight-man box to stop derek
henry are you going to keep two safeties
back to protect i mean you don't know
what if if they can keep these wide
receivers healthy along with derek henry
running football that offense is a
problem but on the flip side they went
out they spent a lot of money brought in
bud dupree spent like 70 million trying
to pay him brought in to nikko autry
that defense is really the difference
maker harold landry he's been
outstanding for him jeffrey simmons they
got linebackers ball and kevin byrd is a
name that we used to say a couple years
ago because he was one of the top
safeties he had a down year last year
he's coming back and he's regaining his
form he's playing outstanding so i like
what the titans are doing man they got
ball players on the defensive side of
the ball and they're playing with the
with the personality of their coach mike
vrabel was a very intense guy very smart
did things right and flew around and
made a lot of plays just like his
defense is doing right now
bayern's playing like the best safety in
football i was just looking at his pff
grade right when he made that point he's
90 plus i mean you never see a 90 plus
at the safety position so he's come all
the way back this season the player that
i think never gets enough credit is tana
hill the quarterback this is one of the
rare situations where there's so much
excitement defensively the run game with
derek henry these two amazing wide
receivers on the outside but when you
watch this football game back tanner
hill is spot on the money consistently
he reads defenses they bring pressure he
throws right behind it this is one of
those throws right here they bring a six
band pressure he floats this thing right
on the back shoulder shortens that step
back shoulder to aj brown he threw
another pass right at the end of the
first quarter was as pretty as you'll
find he drops back it's the wide side of
the field they're on the five yard line
and he throws it to the opposite 40 far
hash aj brown and it's the only guy that
could touch it it's right there so when
he's got some speed too that's the other
thing he's a 4-6 guy nobody thinks about
him like that but down in the red zone
he's running for a handful of touchdowns
this season complete team i'm right
there with you rod the tennessee titans
they're one of those groups like the
bengals right now that they're they're
the class of the afc that's how i'm
seeing the afc right now titans bangles
if you look at the titans too remember
they lost their offense coordinator
arthur smith to the atlanta falcons he
became a head coach so their offense is
still going through a transition taylor
la juan their best offensive lineman
he's not even 100 so this offense this
offense is still going to going through
a transition trying to figure things out
trying to see with the new offense
coordinator how he's going to run
derrick henry how many times like
situational stuff you know what is he
going to do with the guys outside how
he's going to use utilize the tight end
when when are they going to go in 12
personnel all these different things so
they're trying to figure out it hasn't i
mean this is the what the seven eighth
week of the season this is like the
halfway point of the season and they're
still trying to figure out some things
so the titans will only continue to get
better i know mike vravo i know his work
ethic got no attention to detail and
he's gonna stay on those guys
yeah and they had to get healthy a
little bit they needed to get you know
julio back and healthy and now that you
see all those playmakers on the field at
the same time you start thinking oh this
this is this is what the offseason hype
was about this is why because this team
was already close then julio comes in
now julio's healthy aj brown tannehill
the defense you described okay watch out
speaking of getting healthy carson wentz
he had the one sprained ankle then he
had two sprained ankles he's still
trying to play through it he goes out
there to san francisco in the slot
probably remind him of that old
philadelphia weather when he was playing
up there was horrible weather and he
beat the 49ers and pretty soundly carson
wins the turnaround what's your take rod
man i'm you know i was one of those guys
and i was always riding carson wins hard
and even some of the fans let me know
you're always on carson wins but i got
to give a lot of props to head coach
frank wright i mean this guy
i mean you got to give him credit for
turning carson wentz around think about
what they've done they brought him in a
stable environment where the general
manager the head coach and the owner
they're all on the same page so when
he's in this stable environment he loves
the fact that his coach
trusts him have faith in him and now
he's back there he knows he's got a good
offensive line he's got a heck of a
young running back they have a lot of
young talent on this team and i was
talking to general manager chris ballard
and he absolutely loves this team and
the depth that they have and they're
just continuing to try to build carson
wins up but the the the run game that
they have the young defenders that they
have i mean this is going to be a good t
this is a good team and this is going to
be a tough out for somebody if they're
messing with you know because they got
to deal with darius leonard they got to
deal with quentin nelson getting back
and getting healthy
and if ty hilton can get healthy and
stay healthy i mean they could make a
legitimate run jack
we were talking about before on football
night in america this week that it was
that 2018 draft
round one and round two they got quentin
nelson and darius leonard picks one and
two that's a damn good draft those are
foundational pieces for this team moving
forward all pros you told me two of the
best at their respective positions
uh and it's your first buckner deforest
buckler is still young
deforest buckner still yeah you look at
um justin blackman justin blackman the
safety that just got hurt he's still a
young guy they got young players
deforest buckner it's not like he's an
old man you know they have great players
on every level and chris balor is going
to continue to add to him the more
carson wins plays the more reps he's get
the more comfortable he will feel he
will continue to get better
and michael pittman jr
another young guy on the offensive side
of the ball but he looked he was
destroying san francisco's secondary
this game came down to passing
interference that's what ended up losing
the game for san francisco was that the
colts were just throwing the ball up and
just giving the receivers chances and
they weren't even coming down with it
and i think that's what has to be the
most frustrating part if you're a san
francisco fan is make them catch those
balls make them make a play in that
atmospheric river conditions make them
just go come down with it but instead
all these 49ers defensive backs were
just tackling people they're just taking
them down and like never turning their
head to find the ball they're just
playing horrible defense and that's got
to be the most frustrating part it's one
thing to get beat but it's another thing
to give up 90 plus yards in defensive
pass interference and keep putting them
at the one yard line
whose fault is that
it's the defensive coordinators d'amico
ryan now i'm gonna hold him accountable
because if you know that your defensive
backs are struggling with seeing the
ball you don't pray play press coverage
you get them back you play them in zone
where they can always keep vision on the
quarterback and they can play with depth
you play from deep to short so if
anything is caught in front of you you
come up you rally and you make the
tackle you cannot let anything go over
your head if you watch film and
and maybe i watch more tape than them
all i saw is when i was watching indy
was run run run take a shot run run run
take a shot play action pass take a shot
that's all they do that's what they do
and it's it's like how can you be
surprised to mikko because that's what
they do and you know he just didn't make
any adjustments he sits back and he
thinks that he could just rush for but
nothing else changed this is k-1
williams he's one of the best
nickelbacks in all of football
and they're going to throw it up you're
not in great position you don't see the
football just get deep you don't even
have to do this you don't have to grab
the guy how can you grab the guy you see
you know the officials are staring at
you just get deep who cares if he
catches a 10 yard out route this is a
veteran player this is josh norm this
guy's been all pro he's been a pro
bowler and he's doing the same thing so
to me it i'm looking at the defense
coordinator i'm looking at the secondary
coach and i'm saying what the heck are
you guys doing do you watch tape
i just don't get it
it was really ugly it was really ugly
especially when you consider they were
up nine nothing all they had to do was
protect that lead i mean they're up nine
nothing in this game then before you
know what they're losing it was like
they just before it was like at half
time they already had relinquished the
lead at that point so it was just really
a sloppy game i thought shanahan called
such a great opening series where he was
hammering this run game getting that
stretch going to the outside and then he
was working the play action in
beautifully and then after that he
started outsmartering himself a little
bit the run game was working mitchell
was destroying him out of the backfield
but then he started just shifting
strategies look at this run game they
were they were hammering the ball that
first series
mitchell i mean he's not getting touched
until he's eight yards down the field
look at this he's not getting touched
till it's the safety and then they
started going play action on first down
and play action on second down and
garoppolo is just not the caliber player
to go take over the game right now it's
why they traded up gave up all the loot
to go get trey lance and they better be
careful right now john lynch and
shanahan they better be careful because
you already missed on garoppolo now if
you miss on trey lance and you continue
losing all these games it could become a
slippery slope in a hurry out there for
the 49ers their front office what about
brandon iuke
they what about brandon iuke they missed
them another one and thomas the solomon
times thomas
and i look at kyle shanahan and i talked
about this um in our post game show a
lot you know i just he's the head coach
and at the end of the day they gave him
they gave jimmy g 100 million bucks and
if you cannot trust a guy that you gave
100 million dollars to to throw the ball
down the field yeah and at least
challenge the defense then
i mean like what are you doing like he
needs to make a decision because either
he's gonna roll with jimmy g this year
and allow jimmy g to play quarterback or
he should go with trey lance when trey
lance gets back and say you know what
this is the new regime we're gonna stick
with this quarterback and we're gonna
have jimmy g back him up but he needs to
make a decision because right now what
he's doing to his team it's not right
he's not right as a coach right now and
a lot of guys are probably upset at him
too trying to you know figure this thing
out
yeah shanahan last in the league
last in the league garoppolo is with
depth of target so that's that's that
lack of trust that you're talking about
and and this offense has been built on
kittle and so when kittle's out it's
kittle catch and run right it's kittle
creating those unbelievable run blocks
like he does which helps that stretch
run scheme works so well and then it's
also kittle with the catch and run where
you can break three or four tackles and
bust off these big plays debo samuel can
do some of the same stuff but when they
don't have george kittle this offense
just looks flat it looks weak it looks
flat and they fell apart after that
first series i just think it's going to
be
some sort of dicey territory starting to
happen out there right now they got a
lot riding on trey lance becoming a
great quarterback and i think that there
is questionable signs questionable signs
so far based on what i've seen on film
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports